look beneath the rooftops of the world
through all the lands into the houses of
healing
within the past hundred years we have
taken an upward road
where once was despair today there is
knowledge
skill and healing
here the walls echo with the great names
of healing
pastor
airlift
lister
curry
consider the diseases once thought
hopeless
diabetes 30 years ago a lingering death
then in toronto banting and best found
the treatment insulin
tetanus yesterday tetanus killed then
the japanese kitasato found the answer
pernicious anemia death once from boston
came the discoveries of minot murphy and
whipple
with such great victories behind it
science turns to the most fearsome
disease still threatening man
[Music]
[Music]
nasal cell type
is that an artifact there ross probably
macerated a bit in preparation even a
few days ago
malignant
just throw the cheekbone
inclusion body stained well ross
three men concentrating on a lantern
slide a photograph of human tissue
[Music]
some of my colleagues would like to have
a look at you now this is dr mcvicker
and dr rome
matter of fact we've just been having a
look at a slide of your specimen these
gentlemen are research scientists oh
will you put your hat and coat on the
chair please thank you
here is a man whose body is being
undermined by a strange disturbance
this body what is it
how did it begin
[Music]
it begins with a fertilized human egg a
single pinpoint fragment of life the
cell
in this cell lies the power to grow
this it does by dividing
first into two
two into four mitosis the biologist
calls it
the fundamental process of life
into eight
sixteen and so on
growing into a predetermined form
growing into the human embryo
[Music]
as the embryo matures the cells develop
into special structures
[Music]
by the seventh week the embryo is
composed of many millions of cells
grouped according to their function into
developing tissues and organs
some make up the tissues of the hand
others those of the eye
still others from the fetal heart to the
adult heart
from the embryo finally emerges the
complete adult man
and the adult man is an organization of
billions trillions of cells
forming the systems by which he can live
work
and reproduce
muscles
bones
[Music]
a delicate network of blood vessels the
veins the arteries
the tireless muscles of the heart
the food-absorbing villi of the
intestines
the sugar storing cells of the liver
into these and many more as intricate
and marvelous grow the cells
the man is balanced living complete
his body has reached an invisible
boundary line
and the cells stop growing
but sometimes they don't
sometimes something happens to stop them
growing again
uncontrolled outlaws
dividing again
indifferent to the laws and life of the
body of which they are apart they grow
and grow
beyond all normality pressing on healthy
tissues healthy organs
growing
spreading throughout the body to start
new malignant colonies growing without
purpose
disrupting the vital functions of the
body
this is cancer
a very interesting example one of the
most curable of all cancers no pain
tolerance to davis no
mr davis one of the lucky ones
90 chances out of 100 will cure it
thank you mr davis
immediately mr davis
okay doctor thank you
you don't worry now no
your chance going back to that yes i
why should the cancer problem be so
difficult
it's a matter of a cell that won't stop
growing we know that
why not
why can't we find the reason
the world's best minds backed by
millions in research funds are at work
on the problem
why is it taking so long
why is the answer so difficult
it is long
and it is difficult because this tiny
cell
this microscopic unit of life
[Music]
is a very world in itself
a universe to be explored
science is piercing deep into this
universe
in its micron miles detecting
constellations
charting them
naming them
the centrosome
the mitochondria
[Music]
the golgi network
[Music]
the cytoplasm
the nucleus
part of the cell
the chromosomes
[Music]
the nucleolus
decades to chop this minute astronomy
these quivering worlds are spaced out
within one single cell
yet this is only one among the billions
which make up the human body
here in this pinpoint universe lies the
mystery of life
and the riddle of cancer
[Music]
alive in this flask is a tiny bit of
flesh
the beat of time brings a pause to all
living creatures
the span of life is measured out
three years three score and ten
but a bit of flesh taken from this
animal can be kept living
growing
alive
work with bits of living animal tissue
is fundamental today in the field of
cancer investigation
for his experiments the scientists can
grow normal tissue as well as abnormal
in many instances cancer cells have been
grown in glass without losing their
destructive malignant qualities
transferred to a suitable animal they
would kill it
but these bits of tissue no longer able
to draw upon the body itself for life
must be nurtured and nourished with
exacting technique
the conditions under which they will
live demand skillful control
even their feeding must be conducted in
sterile chambers
and they must be fed regularly with
life-giving solutions
in this way both healthy and cancerous
tissue whichever is needed for
experiments can be maintained
tissue can be grown cultured in eggs
also
again under control conditions
the cancer cells are injected into a
fertilized egg
here they grow taking their nourishment
from the chick embryo
and cancer tissue can also be grown in
laboratory animals
tools and techniques for this work may
appear simple but they have taken years
to develop
hundreds of samples
thousands of hours
in many ways laboratory workers find it
useful to experiment with tissue that
has been removed from the body
what effect will various chemicals have
how will the tissue react to changes in
diet
questions
questions about differences between
normal and cancer tissue
the rate of growth can be measured and
recorded stage by stage
like the growth rings of a tree
inside each cell it makes up this living
and growing mass lies the challenge and
the answer
[Music]
within each cell are the nucleus and the
centrosome
locked inside the nucleus lie the tiny
elements which control heredity
these are the chromosomes which will
bestow the characteristics of the parent
cell upon the daughter cell
when the final
birth crisis comes
when the astral body divides in the
quiver of creation
[Music]
when the interlocking chromosomes part
separated
one has become two
sharing a common inheritance
[Music]
what part does heredity play in cancer
i don't know what you think of when you
think of a hero okay
but you're looking at one right now the
most important factor in our experiments
character mouse
this mouse is pretty special we can
learn a lot of things from him and the
other mice in my lab down the hall
for example
why you got to be so much like your
mother
these newborn mice have a family tree
that cannot happen among humans
brothers have been mated to sisters
generation after generation until the
family characteristics of each mouse are
almost completely predictable
these mice will have cancer
ninety percent of their offspring will
also have cancer
and ninety percent of theirs
okay take a look at this one
however a mouse can be bred which will
have very little chance of ever
developing cancer
but men are not mice well let's get
things straightened up here now between
one human generation and the next there
is no precisely known relationship in
cancer
for the inquiring mind the study of
genetics is a journey along the entire
scale of life
a journey from the amoeba to the guinea
pig
from mice to possible applications in
man
when science can say with complete
assurance what part genetic factors play
in cancer in humans
we shall have come to a peak of
discovery
to learn from mice the scientists must
study them for years but only a few
weeks are required to follow the entire
life span of the drosophila the common
fruit fly
in 10 months the scientists can observe
almost 30
generations he has searched into the
mechanics of heredity and found that
chromosomes the carriers of heredity can
be changed by forces outside the cell
the normal fly can be placed under a
bombardment of x-rays
these x-rays strike like a kind of
electric hammer
this can change the chromosomes so
deeply that following generations may
produce new and different variations
mutants
creatures with shriveled wings
freaks
and these can occur in many animal
species in mice for example somersaults
circle is
and what is more the new characteristics
of these animals may be passed on from
generation to generation
is cancer due to something that changes
the chromosomes of a normal cell
[Music]
the world of the cell is like a complex
industrial organism carrying on all the
interlocking functions necessary to life
and growth
it breathes
it feeds
it transports
combines
it divides
[Music]
converts manufactures
[Music]
life
life and growth
do the life functions of the normal cell
differ from those in the cancer cell
if we knew could we disrupt the cancer
cells machinery
[Music]
in these glass containers are bits of
cancer tissue taken from a rat
here with this apparatus the scientist
learns about the breathing of tumor
cells the gases they take in those they
give off
it is part of the great investigation
carried on in laboratories all over the
world
the investigation into the life
processes of living cells
normal cells and cancer cells
there we are
team when you're ready barbara have you
seen reid's article in the new journal
the tracer technique one yeah i looked
at it over the weekend nice bit of
research yeah he's a good man i'd still
like to see more evidence of course
murray
[Music]
[Music]
results are just starting to get
exciting now starting to pay off about
time too
nearly here to get set up
and i think we've got something
it's interesting to speculate what it
means if he's right a lot of theories
will
please ten new questions
that's good to hear
uh how's your grandfather
well we've been pretty lucky that way
they understand the long-range nature of
them say i got a letter from carmilla
this morning oh
[Music]
patience time
persistence
there is no royal road to facts to
knowledge to understanding
no royal road to easy answers
no easy answers to great and baffling
questions
[Music]
can something from outside the body
invade the cell to change its behavior
what is there in our environment that
may affect itself
[Music]
we are beginning to understand the exact
relationship between the world around us
and the occurrence of cancer
investigators carefully following up
known cases are searching for the pieces
of a puzzle
pursuing a clue
we've learned for example that people
who spend a lifetime of exposure
outdoors constantly under the sun's rays
are more apt to develop skin cancer than
indoor workers
when we find enough clues we can begin
to plan means of prevention
we need facts statistical studies we can
analyze
[Music]
[Music]
every promising line of inquiry is being
followed
family patterns job history
will a thousand cases point to a common
factor
statistics
changing technology exposure to new
chemicals
are certain cancers more common among
people in particular industries
is there a tendency to be observed
statistics throwing light on the mystery
are certain cancers more common to men
and to women
statistics
facts to be studied
is there something in our daily work
that starts it off
science is examining every known suspect
samples collected from a hundred places
breaking them down in an attempt to find
the deadly factor
research has advanced far since that
year of 1918 when japanese scientists
produced a tumor on the ear of a rabbit
by painting it with tar
since then scientists have found
hundreds of compounds that can start
cancers put together models of the
molecular structures
how's it coming anyway well we isolated
an active fraction
should look something like this this is
your hydroxyl group
we're not too sure about the amino group
probably here yeah
applied to our daily work such research
can test the effects of the chemicals we
use perhaps help to prevent cancer
but for science there are still the
questions how and why does the chemical
start cancer
what does it do to the cell
[Music]
questions to be answered and the answers
are coming
and because of this constant search and
research
a man can approach the thought of
treatment with confidence
there is much that can be done now that
was impossible even a few years ago
each day we make some progress
[Music]
in the unseen laboratories behind
hospital walls scientists are working
with the sensitive tools that may lead
to additional weapons for healing
the exploration of known and new fields
continues
there is radium therapy the patient work
that has produced and refined it
little tubes milligrams of radium
applied near the cancer growth
radium dosage size and strength still
being minutely study
[Music]
there are radioactive isotopes
atomic energy turned to the uses of man
some cancers of the thyroid gland for
example have shown signs of yielding to
this new technique
there is the geiger counter itself
its electric crackle a yardstick to
measure and follow radioactive compounds
within the body
radioactive iodine carbon sodium
phosphorus
it is against this background of
research that the patient with cancer is
being treated
[Music]
in the field of x-ray therapy
multi-million voltage weapons for
producing more effective and more
penetrating radiation are being
developed
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm just going to position this machine
and bring the comb right down until it's
resting on my cheek
[Music]
can you tell me if this is too tight mr
davis yes
mr davis will be cured
but not all are as lucky as mr davis
there are those with cancers which
unlike his give few warning signs
there may be no pain in the beginning
they lie hidden in the body
and again with the great advances in
surgical techniques the outlook is good
the majority of cases brought to medical
care this year can be effectively
treated
but it must be found soon enough
that is why science is searching for a
test
a reliable test that will find cancer
early while it still can be cured
[Music]
leaving right away
kids in bed
he did
oh well put a band-aid on he'll be all
right in the morning
what bill i paid that bill the beginning
of the month sure
from his first lesson in kindergarten it
takes perhaps 20 years of study to make
a scientist
the jones
no i don't want to go there tom we can't
go
he is a man like other men
but also he is a man whose intelligence
has been alerted his imagination given
special edge
he has stored within him a vast fund of
knowledge drawn from the scientific
harvest of the world
and in him is the agitation of a problem
he did
oh
this search
the question mark
there are men like this in places like
this in montreal and washington new york
and paris
london
rome
geneva stockholm
what is man that thou art mindful of him
here a challenge lies
and here a challenge has been accepted
a steady unheroic search for a shaft of
light
and the light may come from any work
from the study of an animal or a plant
root for cancer is common to almost all
living things
[Music]
on this bench on that one in this lab
and that the search goes on the search
for our answer each passing day
progress
the pursuit of an idea the exchange of
new knowledge all over the world
who is to say when the answer will
finally come
[Music]
it is the answer to life for which the
students of science are searching and
the problem is great
but we are surrounding it closing in on
it
more and more new minds highly trained
and training others equipped with every
skill and technique of the 20th century
are applying themselves to the work
the answer will come from the effort of
many men and women the doctor the nurse
the chemist the biologist the physicist
the mathematician
all these and more advanced in the
dedicated search
behind them will be the victories of
other scientists
and when the answer does come finally
they will have ventured far along the
corridor of a universe
we um come again this morning to our
discussion of the self
we continue to turn to it inevitably
doing so i would ask you to bear in mind
that we're dealing here with an enormous
problem
the problem of life itself
can we have the projection please
[Music]
it is on this
on the cell and the mysteries it holds
that science
today converges
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
you